what does Victory look like and that's
not been clarified even a year after the
invasion itself and I think the West
needs to come to terms with the fact
this isn't just about Ukraine this is
Russia having a go at the West as a
whole probably
um in alignment and support with China
in the background providing the weapons
components that Russia needs to keep
this going this is much much bigger than
just Ukraine and the quicker we put the
fire out in the Ukraine the quicker we
can reduce inflation down to about you
know four to five four to five percent
um which will make it easier to then pay
for all these other things that we've
been speaking about you get the grains
coming out of Odessa for example that
will help reduce the cost of living
prices so again it's in our interests to
be less hesitant less risk-averse stop
being spooked by Putin and start to help
Ukraine in the scale that they actually
require it